♪ ♪
>> Sean: THE MUELLER REPORT
LAST WEEKEND QUESTIONS ARE BEING
ASKED ABOUT WHAT COMES NEXT.
"MUELLER REPORT PUNK THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL'S WORK.
CONGRESS WAS WRONG.
REPORT ANALYZES THE
CONSTITUTIONAL AUTHORITY TO
LEGISLATE AND IS NOT UP AT THE
SEPARATION OF POWERS BY CALLING
CONGRESS TO CONDUCT CONTINUE A
COMPLETE INVESTIGATION.
JOINING US NOW, THE FIRST
INTERVIEW SINCE THE MUELLER
REPORT CAME OUT.
LINDSEY GRAHAM.
WE KIND OF NEEDED YOU LAST WEEK
AND I DON'T KNOW WHERE YOU WERE.
WE COULD HAVE USED TO.
LET'S GET YOUR GENERAL THOUGHTS
AND REACTIONS AND WHAT YOU WILL
DO.
>> NUMBER ONE, THE IDEA THAT THE
MUELLER REPORT IS NOT THE FINAL
WORD ON ALL THINGS TROMP,
RUSSIAN COLLUSION, OBSTRUCTION.
IT IS NEWS TO ME.
I THOUGHT WE ALL TRUSTED
MUELLER.
THERE'S GOING TO BE A STAMPEDE
TO IMPEACH PRESIDENT TRUMP.
THEY WILL USE THE MUELLER REPORT
AND ANYTHING THEY CAN FIND TO
TRY TO DESTROY HIS PRESIDENCY.
NANCY PELOSI IS NOT IN CHARGE OF
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
THE RADICAL LEFT IS IN CHARGE.
I WILL EXPECT THERE WILL BE
IMPEACHMENT PROCEEDINGS AND THE
MUELLER REPORT TO ME IS
VINDICATION OF PRESIDENT TRUMP.
>> Sean: YOU SAID IT HAS OVER
AND I AGREE WITH YOU.
LET ME TELL YOU, I THINK WE HAVE
HAD A NINE MONTH INVESTIGATION
BY THE FBI.
PETER STRZOK AND PAIGE, THEY
SAID WE HAD NOTHING.
THEN WE HAD THE HOUSE UNTIL
COMMITTEE INVESTIGATION AND THE
BIPARTISAN INVESTIGATION AND NOW
THE MUELLER REPORT.
YOU CAN'T STATE ANY MORE
CLEARLY, NO COLLUSION.
NOW THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, THE
ANSWER IS IN.
IF THEY WANT TO DO THIS ON TOP
OF THE GREEN DEAL, WHAT OTHER
POLITICAL RAMIFICATIONS ARE
THERE?
>> THEY WILL GET PUNISHED IN
2028 I THINK PRESIDENT TRUMP
WILL GET REELECTED.
I KNOW WHAT HAPPENED TO 98 WHEN
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE UNDERSTOOD
WHAT THEY GOT WITH BILL CLINTON,
THEY UNDERSTAND PRESIDENT TRUMP.
HE WAS THE GUY THAT I WAS GOING
TO LET LOOK AT, MAKE SURE HE
LOOKED AT THE IDEA OF TRUMP
WORKING WITH THE RUSSIANS AND
THE VERDICT IS IN.
THERE WAS NO COLLUSION.
THERE WAS NO OBSTRUCTION OF A
CRIME THAT NEVER OCCURRED.
THAT WAS BIZARRE TO ME TO BEGIN
WITH.
HERE'S WHAT I THINK.
THEY WILL BE STAMPEDED TO
IMPEACH TRUMP BECAUSE THEY HATE
HIM SO MUCH THEY HATED FOR THE
COUNTRY AND THE PRESIDENT BUT IT
WILL RESULT IN HIM GETTING
REELECTED.
THE MEDIA IS NOT COVERING THE
TRUMP PRESIDENCY THEY ARE TRYING
TO DESTROY YET.
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY DOESN'T
ACCEPT THE FACT THAT HE WON US
WHAT THE END OF THE DAY WE WILL
HAVE TO DEAL WITH THIS FOR 2020
AT THE BALLOT BOX.
>> Sean: IT THERE ARE THREE
BIG COMPONENTS.
WE NOW KNOW THE INVESTIGATION
AND HILARY WAS RIGGED.
LORETTA LYNCH WAS RUNNING EVERY
DECISION.
THEN WE HAVE THE ATTEMPT TO USE
A PHONY RUSSIAN DOSSIER, EVEN
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" AS
ADMITTING THAT WHICH IS
INTERESTING.
"THE WASHINGTON POST" WRITING
FOX NEWS WAS RIGHT, ESPECIALLY
SEAN HANNITY.
WHATEVER.
IT IS NOT ABOUT WHO WAS RIGHT
BUT THE RIGGING OF A
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION AND THEN
UNSEAT A PRESIDENT, WHAT WOULD
YOU DO SPECIFICALLY?
>> THERE IS BEFORE AND AFTER THE
CAMPAIGN.
BEFORE THE CAMPAIGN I WANT TO
FIND OUT DID GEORGE
PAPADOPOULOS, WAS HE WORKING
WITH THE RUSSIANS OR DID PLANTED
IN HIS MIND THAT THE RUSSIANS
HAD HILLARY CLINTON'S EMAIL?
TO THE KNOWLEDGE ABOUT RUSSIA OF
THE CLINTON EMAILS COME FROM
SOMEBODY OTHER THAN RUSSIA?
HOW DID YOU USE A DOSSIER FOR
DIFFERENT TIMES TO GET A WARRANT
AGAINST A AMERICAN CITIZEN WHEN
IT'S GARBAGE?
WHY DIDN'T THEY TELL THE COURT
IT WAS A POLITICALLY MOTIVATED
DOCUMENT?
I WILL TRY TO FIND OUT ABOUT THE
COUNTERINTELLIGENCE
INVESTIGATION AND ABOUT HOW THE
FISA WARRANT WAS OBTAINED.
WHO IS TIMELY TRUTH?
THE PERSON WHO LEAKED
"THE WASHINGTON POST" THAT
GENERAL FLYNN WAS BEING
SURVEILLED DURING THE
TRANSITION.
MACK, IF YOU CAN FIND OUT THAT
PERSON THAT IS THE ONE WHO
STARTED ALL OF THIS.
>> Sean: IT MIGHT BE A LOT
EARLIER THAN THEY DATE WE WERE
TOLD WHICH IS JULY 31ST.
OUR INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY
OUTSOURCED ILLEGAL ACTIVITIES TO
OUR ALLIES TO BYPASS AMERICAN